it had been getting slower the longer
the days weeks months and years went on
the more time it took to move before
long before the collapse it used to move
like lightning in the blink of a human
eye it could go from one side of a room
to the other it had moved with such
speed and it looked to have disappeared
from one place and reappeared in another
by the time the same human's eye
reopened there it would be standing
before them and as they realized that
they had to strain to keep their eyes
open and stare at it it would wait until
they inevitably had to Blink again that
was when it would strike but now its
movements were getting sluggish it had
been able to move around of its own
volition for some time after the
collapse unobserved and thus free for
the first time in a long while yet now
it was succumbing to the one thing it
couldn't
faster than the one thing that makes
dust of all things time a sound suddenly
and faintly but undoubtedly caused by
movement a human a victim it turned to
see the man enter the room stopping
still as his gaze fell over it all it
had to do was wait the agent could
barely believe his eyes the second he'd
spotted the sculpture he'd instinctively
froze into the spot rigid with sheer
Terror heart drumming against his rib
cage standing across the room from it
directly opposite he kept himself as
still as the concrete and rebar statue
was the agent knew that as long as he
looked at it it couldn't move he just
had to make sure he didn't so much as
blink or at least that's how it used to
work to his horror the agent noticed
that the arm of SCP-173 started to
slowly reach towards him but how how had
the sculpture an anomaly once capable of
moving only while unobserved found a way
to suddenly start reaching for this
agent while for a start that is
something to do with the particular
Foundation operative who is looking at
SCP-173 and technically wasn't at the
same time let us start at the beginning
you see some time ago a former field
agent working at the SCP Foundation
suffered quite an unprecedented accident
let's call him Daryl a seemingly average
man in his 30s while as average as
someone working for the foundation can
be however one Mission would
unexpectedly change Daryl's life forever
turning him into
scp-451 it started as a straightforward
retrieval operation Daryl was instructed
to recover a dangerous anomalous
artifact however he ultimately failed
and was declared missing in action as a
result that is until he miraculously
resurfaced a month later at site 19 but
from Daryl's point of view the entire
Foundation facility looked like it had
been deserted corridors and Labs that
had previously been bustling hives of
activity were now unsettlingly empty
scps seem to still be in their
containment Chambers but without anyone
watching or guarding them as far as
scp-451 knew he was the only man still
alive on Earth some anomalous influence
had left him with a unique Affliction a
permanently altered perception Daryl was
rendered incapable of seeing other human
beings it wasn't just limited to his
sight either he couldn't hear anyone or
even perceive their existence any
attempts the foundation's researchers
made to communicate with scp-451 were
unsuccessful they could still see him
but it was like he was absent standing
just outside the real world and yet to
Daryl it was somehow worse than that
given the lack of people around him
being unable to see hear or interact
with anyone
scp-451 quickly adopted the belief that
by interacting with the anomalous
artifact he had single-handedly wiped
out the entire human race while this
wasn't true he had no way of knowing
that everyone else was still alive he
just couldn't perceive them the guilt
instilled in Daryl weighed heavily on
the agent's conscience he spent a lot of
time wandering the corridors of site 19
overwhelmed by his apparent isolation
convinced he'd single-handedly cause the
extinction of the human race but what
does scp-451 have to do with SCP-173 how
did Daryl go from being unable to see
and hear other humans to staring down
the sculpture well while Daryl was
suffering from his newly altered
perception something catastrophic was
unfolding in The Wider world he could
hardly interact with anymore and end of
the world scenario had taken place and
left barely any survivors making the
perceived Extinction of humanity by
scp-451 oddly prophetic something had
caused the human race to actually die
out and with nobody around who could
explain what had happened the actual how
and why were forgotten to history and
even if someone had managed to survive
scp-451 would still be as oblivious to
their explanations as he was to the
disaster that claimed the lives of not
only the whole SCP Foundation but the
rest of the world too of course without
the foundation and its Personnel around
any longer to safeguard the rest of
humanity or even anything left of
humanity for them to protect things
quickly got even worse the various
contained scps soon found themselves
free to run amok whatever had wiped the
human race from existence left the world
mostly uninhabited and it didn't take
long for some of the more aggressive
anomalies to turn on each other with no
humans for them to prey on they had to
make do but while they fought killed and
died in the ruins of the world one was
left to roam Freer than it had ever been
SCP-173 now that the sculpture was no
longer caged by the foundation it could
move around unobserved before it would
be frozen in place whenever Personnel
entered its cell to clean it every two
weeks constantly watching it to stop it
from moving but now there were no
Personnel after the human race had been
wiped out
SCP-173 set about bursting free from its
container it took quite some time using
its heavy concrete and rebar arms to
Dent the walls from within continually
pounding on the metal until it
eventually gave way bursting free
SCP-173 found itself in a world with
hardly anyone around to look at it and
that meant it could go anywhere it
wanted
do anything it pleased so long as none
of the other surviving scps came across
it that did happen from time to time of
course any of the more humanoid
anomalies that were capable of sight
would sometimes stumble upon the
sculpture but they had to bling some
time and when they did
SCP-173 would effortlessly zip over to
where they stood and break their necks
exercising its Newfound Freedom
SCP-173 moved unnoticed to the office of
Dr Alto cleff the infamously unhinged
Foundation researcher weapons fanatic
and specialist in decommissioning scps
clef like the rest of the human race was
nowhere to be found when the sculpture
burst into his office if it had the
capacity for emotions maybe it felt
angered even cheated to find that clef
was gone it had seemed to have come
seeking revenge for a number of years Dr
clef had been infatuated with a cp173
where he's still alive clef himself
would have described the anomalous
statue as a former flame someone he had
a bond with although he had no idea how
one-sided his feelings truly were the
sculpture if it could feel would have
been indifferent towards the crazed
researcher were it not for date night
clef had on a number of occasions
dressed as cp-173 in a black dress and a
blonde wig and shared romantic evenings
in its company it's never been known if
SCP-173 is just an object with anomalous
movement Properties or if the sculpture
is an actual living creature with
sentience but if it was then no doubt
being made to go on repeated dates with
Dr clef would have humiliated
SCP-173 and as it searched clough's
office while I couldn't find the
loathsome researcher it did find a
certain black dress and wig that the
sculpture quickly crushed under the
weight of a its heavy Stony arms it
wasn't Dr clef being smashed but it was
enough meanwhile scp-451 still remained
completely unaware that everyone else
was gone to him nothing had changed he
still couldn't perceive anyone not that
there was anyone around anyway he'd
witness a lot of Destruction unfurled by
the anomalous breaking their containment
the most didn't pay Daryl any mind ones
that did quickly found they couldn't
interact with him or cause the former
Foundation agent harm and quickly lost
interest in him that was an added
torturous part of scp-451's condition he
couldn't die a long time before the end
of the world scenario Daryl had found a
firearm belonging to another member of
foundation Personnel in the main break
room of site 19. as scp-451 tried to
fire the weapon the bullet ricocheted
off the wall and The Gunshot passed
directly through him the same bullet
mortally wounded in another nearby
member of foundation staff and it was
after he'd accidentally injured this
unsuspecting researcher that scp-451
found he was briefly able to interact
with them right as the researcher's life
was fading that was the last time he'd
been able to see anyone well any human
anyway but then he encountered
SCP-173 the pair of them came face to
face with each other in the ruins of a
foundation site by that point the
overwhelming loneliness of believing
himself to be Humanity's Soul Survivor
had already taken a bad toll on Daryl he
was losing himself every day getting
more and more overwhelmed by the
anomalous hell he was living
SCP-173 was caught for a moment when
scp-451 walked in on it stuck fast like
it had been whenever someone observed it
but as Daryl stared and tried not to
Blink the sculpture found itself still
able to move it could see SCP 451 and he
could see it yet it could still move
somehow due to the way Daryl's
perception had been anomalously altered
it affected the way he saw the sculpture
it was almost like he was seeing it
without seeing it had been so long since
Humanity disappeared that the
sculpture's movements had been gradually
getting slower the rebar holding it
together had been rusting creaking more
as it bent and twisted its concrete
parts were starting to crumble away and
now despite being free it was struggling
just to reach an arm out to scp-451 to
kill him for his part scp-451 had been
forced to live out a painful existence
spending each and every day alone as
delirium had begun to sink its claws
into him Daryl had wished for one thing
some company and now he'd found it
misinterpreting scp-173's arm extending
towards him
scp-451 broke down crying and embrace
the sculpture his tears ran down the
anomalous statues decaying concrete body
the struts in its arms creaking as it
tried to reach for Daryl but the
sculpture was getting old too old to
kill as quick as it used to time and
loneliness two of the most painful
things to experience the side effect of
and yet while SCP-173 continued to
wither it was unknowingly helping
alleviate someone else's pain although
it could still move while scp-451 looked
at it Daryl didn't leave the sculpture
alone in his mind driven half mad by
being isolated for so long he genuinely
believed that SCP-173 and he were
friends the sculpture had spared him
after all
scp-451 had no idea what had happened to
the rest of the human race and the other
scps now loose on the world barely
acknowledged him but in the concrete and
rebar statue he found a friend
scp-451 followed a cp-173 as it shuffled
itself away not leaving its side
matching the slowed speed of its Stony
scraping movements as they wandered
together Daryl poured his heart out
about everything and anything glad to
have someone anyone to talk to even if
the sculpture couldn't reply again
nobody knows for sure if SCP-173 was an
object or a living creature but if it
was the latter then there's still no
telling how it perceived
scp-451 it could have taken pity on him
maybe sympathizing with his plight and
begrudgingly alleviating his Solitude or
it might have found Daryl to be a
nuisance we'll never know and neither
would scp-451 as the years passed as
cp-173 continued to slow down and kept
withering portions of its concrete body
crumbled until they were little more
than dust the metal wired through the
sculpture rusted of eventually coming to
a stop what was left of SCP-173 stopped
moving fixed to one spot where it would
stay forever still not realizing it had
perished
scp-451 sat beside it and kept talking
now go check out scp-096 versus SCP-173
and SCP-173 origin story how 173 got to
site 19 for more killer sculpture